my head
brilliant thank you welcome everyone to
the meeting of the
cabinet of northeast arbitrary district
council
uh it's uh the 12th of november 2020
uh it's 4 30 and we're ready to start so
firstly if we can have apologies for
absence
uh i've had them received from uh
councillor foster
and councillor kenyon uh i don't believe
there are any others
on receive chair right brilliant
uh okay okay could have mentioned lee
hicken
oh yeah okay yeah thanks matt um yeah
lee he can as well then from the office
design
okay uh a minute to the last meeting
have you had a chance to review those
and if so can we uh
confirm them as a true accurate record
have a proposal
alan seconded by paul all those in favor
brilliant thank you very much is that
for the minutes of the 8th of october
29th of october oh yes okay yeah okay
yeah i'm assuming we're all happy with
both yeah yeah sorry
brilliant thank you uh and then we come
to the first paper which
is the uh presentation of the outcomes
for funding for the voluntary and
community organizations for the
uh the past financial year so i'll hand
over to you councillor powell to
introduce this one
um thank you chair
this is a report we've seen before we
did ask for some amendments to it
and those amendments have been made and
the first one was um
that um we make clear that this was um
the the figures referred to were from
the previous administration
and that is referred to in 1.6 um
and we also made it clear that each
each of the organizations provided their
own um
evidence which is what is uh what is
absolutely reported
in the report apart from that uh there
are no differences whatsoever
those amendments have been made and i
therefore um
that we receive this report
okay yeah happy to uh have to second
that and obviously it's only a report
for uh
i think it only is only being noted so
it probably doesn't require a vote i'm
assuming
yeah okay but thank you for that we'll
move on to the next paper uh
which is uh the empty property strategy
so back over to you council of powell
well thank you um the report provides
the governor with details of the
proposed empty property
strategy it's a document that we have
seen before
but again we requested some amendments
to it
um those were principally to um
to up the number of uh long-term
properties that we
that we should aim to bring into use so
those figures have been up to by 50
and i think that is achievable and it's
gone from 10 to 15 if you want the
actual numbers
that's uh that's referred to in 6.2
um i think it is achievable and i hope
we will certainly do
it um the other the other element that
we wanted
um looking at and demanding and
including in the report
was that we should explore the council
tax premium
which this council has never done before
um
if you remember we noted that there were
some upsides and downsides
and that we needed more data the report
says that we are
we are going to look at that data and
come back with a recommendation at some
point in the future
um so those are the only changes to the
document that have already been seen by
uh cabinet members um and therefore i
recommend it to you
okay thanks alan yeah i think the uh the
police to see an increase in the in the
target and what was uh
originally proposed it's an ambitious
target but i think we should
absolutely aim to achieve that because
it is important that we bring empty
properties back into use
i think the issue around council tax is
an important one obviously none of us
would
uh would want to uh increase council
taxes for
uh for residents or property owners
unnecessarily but we do have a duty to
an obligation to ensure that um
you know that we don't that we don't sit
with large numbers of
empty properties over long periods of
time so i think it's important that we
that we do investigate what balance to
to strike with that so um would look
forward to seeing
some more information and a suggestion
uh in in the future on that
uh council of powell's proposed i'm
happy to
second are there any other comments
before we move to the vote
no okay all those in favor
thank you okay that's carried uh and
then
uh we move on to the
single equality scheme uh so councillor
foster's not
able to be with us today so i'll hand
over to kath drewery who's going to give
us
a bit of a bit of a summary of this
report
okay thank you uh so as noted in the
report then this is the first review of
the single equality scheme that runs
from 2019 to 2023
the scheme provides a framework for
implementing the council's obligations
with regard to the general and specific
equality duties
and the council in addition to that set
for objectives that run through the
scheme
so at appendix one you can see a range
of
evidence and all the good works that the
council have been doing so
all sorts of information there from
safeguarding training and guidance
access and support we've strengthened
the area around apprenticeships which
was based on some of the feedback
from informal cabinets so there's now a
very good update on apprenticeships and
we've also covered in there
the local offer for children in care and
care leaver so it's made it
more comprehensive there but as the
appendix
shows there's plenty of uh things that
the council have been doing
under the objectives and the
public sector duties so i think there's
a lot of uh
good things in there and obviously
things that we can build on going
forward and that also are captured in
the
council plan so i'm sure there'll be
future things to
develop in the coming years as well
brilliant thanks thanks cap i'm happy to
to move this paper it is really pleasing
to see there's quite a lot of
achievements there in terms of
our duties under the um the the single
equality scheme
um you know lots of work still ongoing
in terms of uh
bsl uh and the deaf community obviously
very pleased to see the
uh the work around that we've been doing
around children and caring care leaders
um as well as a variety of other things
like the older older people strategy
and the armed forces covenant um i think
he's mentioned in there somewhere
uh it is yeah um so yeah i'm very
very happy to to propose this
that we accept it uh seconded by
councillor renick thank you
and then all those in favor
brilliant that was carried thank you
very much
uh and then we move
get back to the agenda we moved to any
urgent items
there are none from me and then in terms
of exclusion of the press and public
i will move that the public be excluded
from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12a
of the local government act
1972 so thank you very much for joining
us
and and hope you found it useful
you